let's say I've pitched this producer
I've gotten their contact info now
they're emailing me back saying I kind
of like your idea we'll call it um
shearing Santa okay this is the this is
the one this is the Christmas Christmas
in a in a barber shop or hair stylist so
what am I do if they say I'd like to
meet with you or can you send it to me
in a PDF or what's happening yeah at
that point once they like the idea they
want to get the full script they'll get
the full script they'll read it they'll
say okay I read it I like either one of
two things going to happen well maybe
one or three either they hate it they
like it as is although like it with a
few tweaks and changes and a lot of that
will be some character stuff that again
they know what the network is looking
for you know and so they'll ask you hey
can you do
this um but we're going to need some
tweaks and changes and at that point
then you guys will kind of like have a
discussion about money they'll sign you
on there'll be a contract and then at
that point they'll have you start doing
some work at what point are I meeting
face to face with this person at any
point yeah oh yeah most definitely I I
you know if they like it and you know
there's going to be a contract you'll
probably have a meeting you know face to
face at that point if they're in the
same city as you oh I see okay so I'm
finding this producer and they can then
walk it into one of these networks
exactly and Shop it yeah and and so
there's a couple of ways that that that
it could happen I mean there's a world
where so
on the business side there is this
magical list and the Magical list has
names of actors that will sell overseas
so what they'll probably do is um they
they already have a deal with with the
network so they don't need to walk it
into them quite yet what they will say
is hey look we you know we have a three-
pitcher deal we've done two pitches I
have one more left I have an idea for
one um that I'm work I'm developing
right now they'll probably would they
may they may even ask you for um for a
treatment even though you may not have
one you may have to go back and write a
treatment because they might they might
have to give this treatment to the
network to let the network know what
exactly is being worked on and developed
um and then at that point they'll go
ahead and a couple things could happen
number one the network will read the
treatment they like okay here's the
money go make it or the producer before
he even takes it to any network he says
you know I like this so much I want to
just make it and if they don't have the
money necessary to make it themselves
they will actually
pre-sale the uh the
movie based upon the talent that they
attach to it which goes which goes back
to that list I was telling you about
there's certain talents a lot of them
were like 1990
sitcom people that are really big in
France and Germany and whatever and what
they'll do is they'll pre-sale those
territories get the money if not 100%
close to it you know 50% 60% of that
money to actually go ahead and shoot
this on their own and then what they'll
do is they'll shoot this on their own
they'll get they'll get all the money go
shoot this on their own then they'll
sell it to the highest bidder any
network so that's how that's another way
that they can actually do it at that
point right there so within this you
know they give you some money here
here's $25,000 $30,000 $20,000 for for
your writing thank you very much you'll
have no residuals cuz it's it's an Onan
job but it's done you get your first
writer's credit and now they kind of own
it and they'll sell it to these to these
territories
pre-sale it will show on Lifetime or
Hallmark or whatever and then after it's
done its due diligence there they this
this executive producer could
technically they could take it and
resell it to another another um um
service another Network another
streaming service and Amazon and that
money that comes from that doesn't go to
you cuz it's nonunion they can pocket
that money so once they own it they kind
of own it so as a screenwriter are you
only paid once for the project again for
a non-un job non-union yeah which most
of these um Christmas movies are
non-union oh okay yeah so most of those
are going to be non-union jobs doesn't
necessarily mean non-union Talent
working on it but behind the scenes
correct so it'll be non-union in the
sense of they'll be it won't be director
skilled it won't be writer skilled but
it will be sagger after are they shot in
Canada mostly or here they're shot all
over the place Canada is a big place of
course but no a lot of them are shot
here as well um Atlanta um places that
you can get the you know take advantage
of the tax credit because you need to
try to these are not going to be big
budgeted projects these are going to be
between 350,000 to maybe
750,000 um so they're not big budgets so
you need to extend that money as long as
possible and any state where you can
take you know eventually the tax credit
that's a great place to be Canada has a
tax credit as well but the way that
works up there is um the majority of the
crew below the line have to be from
Canada and are many of these Christmas
film sort of just one season wonders or
do they do they play again in other
years probably next year yeah it depends
on the network
um it depends on the network and the and
response they got the first time if the
response they got from the first the
first time is great then yeah they will
play it again no you won't get a check
as the writer um there'll be some checks
for those that are the actors um and it
also could open up the possibility of a
part two ah okay yeah interesting so if
you look at a lot of the Hallmark movie
um versions uh where it's like um I
forgot the name of it but like one that
takes about or talks about maybe it's
even
Netflix um a this woman who married a
prince it was really big I think a
couple a couple of Christmases ago um
she married a prince and people loved it
and so they did a part two of it so yeah
it
happens